before we start the simulation there's
just two questions i want to ask
one is getting tomorrow's a one-way
ticket
well it's a return trip if you can
afford it
okay the probability of getting there is
it a suicide mission
we're all going to die whatever planet
we're on
[Music]
today is a great day this isn't actually
my real smile
it's a mask but it definitely represents
how i feel on the inside
because i'm on my way to go and meet my
astronaut friend dr adriana murray
now how did i become friends with not
just an astronaut
but one that's going to mars i mean
freaking mars
anyways if you want to find out how i
snuck in or
or broke behind the curtain of real life
space sci-fi i'll link the video below
where i allegedly or whatever the term
is that makes it not actually
me or could have been me that's still
unverified
breaking into an underground mars
facility where i found
mars rovers and biomes being built
and this led to a conversation back and
forth by email between myself and dr
adriana maria
i really really need to shine more light
on and emphasize that
she's an incredible woman that's not
only going to mars
she has credentials that make me feel
completely useless
as well as has one of the most
fascinating minds in the world so go
check that out if you haven't already
and then
talking about checking how's about
hearing something awesome
and that comes from only the base of the
business and the sponsors of this video
epidemic sound which is the greatest and
most unique sound and music library out
there
i have absolutely no idea what she has
planned but all i can imagine
is the gnarliest mars simulations
[Music]
wind and ice and all the special
tech stuff
so mars is nothing like that i think i
recognize this costume from a party i
ordered two years back
it's about power water food
communications and the most fundamental
being
shelter i don't know that sounds
pretty boring it was at this point i
realized the astronaut suits
were a terrible idea and that my long
drive up the coast
filled with wonder and dreams fueled
from being an ambitious kid that
definitely at some point
wanted to be an astronaut we're fading
away and that there were no
gigantic mars simulations
it's rather about reversing the cloud
tens of thousands of years backwards
figuring out how to develop
life on mars from the ground up which dr
adriana maria has already started doing
with what she refers to as phase zero by
building this beautiful
self-sustainable home which is literally
in the middle of nowhere land
[Music]
it takes about an hour or so to hike
down to and
it's just slippery as all hell
i know you're disappointed about the the
suits and everything but i've actually
brought you here because i want to show
you a secret
like a space rover no
but older than that older
there's evidence that this region is the
region on the planet where homo sapiens
first emerged
so this wait okay we went from mars
to know a story about the first human
being that trotted along the earth
it's all about survivability whatever
planet you're on
where is this this place let's go
what you're about to witness is
groundbreaking evidence in the research
of human life on our planet
and i'm just so grateful that dr adriana
maria let me reveal this to you
and take me in person to experience the
first phase of such a cosmic
breakthrough
[Music]
disclaimer all official channels have
been pursued and all the legal protocols
have been followed regarding this
discovery
that's a full-on
ancient human skull humans have been
dwelling in these
forest valleys and coastal region for
over 150 000 years but that
that would mean life on earth
could have begun here are we owed to
generations to come
to think very carefully about how we
live out our days and what kind of
culture we want to perpetuate
so ultimately the migration to mars is
about
maintaining the resilience of human
subsistence what we see now is a
massively fast rates of
the evolution of technology and of the
way we live so we just
need to keep a very careful sight of the
core characteristics that have enabled
us to get this far
these tools enable us to survive um what
we do beyond that
in terms of our arts and our music and
celebration of culture
depends on survivability i'm mind blown
i had a completely different idea of
what we were going to be doing
[Music]
there was one one quick thing that i
forgot to ask i've got this extreme
fascination
for sounds and i really wanted to ask
what song mars would make so one of the
things about mars is that you will never
know
to expose your eardrums uh to that very
low pressure with other protective
helmets
is not a good option remember the
pressure on mars
is like a hundred times less than the
pressure at sea level on earth
because i was just expecting that kid
so when you go would you can you send me
a voice note
take take the phone out of your like
little suit thing and
then give me the sound and then and then
i'll be like
the first sound of mars definitely um
well the first voice notes received from
mars
and then once i do receive the first
voice notes ever received from mars
i'll make sure to upload it to epidemic
sound for you to download
therefore make sure to click on the link
in the description below and sign up
today
now back to the future the past or mars
this is not the final stage of
preparation by the way
we're not gonna launch i'm ready this
afternoon yeah we've got a bit more
preparation to do
and artic is on the cards this is
probably the closest approximation
to the kind of conditions that the first
cruise will face on mars
um so this is phase zero you're going to
do that yeah yeah
i was in that article oh you really did
it no no i went for four days we'll go
for the whole year
you're currently in a relationship yes
um so he would be going with you yeah as
the alien consultant
okay i guess that leaves
for another episode the alien consultant
and don't forget you're awesome brew and
i'll see you next
well depends if i'm if i'm off to mars
or not but if i'm still on earth
i'll see you next week
[Music]
you